this is the Panasonic zt60 it's a smart
TV coming out later this year and one of
its most interesting features is that it
has an electronic touch pen you can use
to draw on photos using the pen is
pretty simple you touch and hold the
screen and then you can pick some colors
start drawing you can save it and it
gets delivered to a mobile device over
Wi-Fi and then you can close out and go
back to watching live TV we played
around with this set for a bit and it
did crash sometimes so we're not quite
sure if it's ready for prime time and
we're also not quite sure why you would
really want to do this in your living
room I think it's much easier to edit
photos on your laptop or on your tablet
where you have a greater degree of
control and you're not you know standing
up in front of your TV maybe getting
fingerprints on it but I think it could
be useful in offices and boardrooms
where maybe you're marking up documents
so everyone can see so maybe you'll have
a place or maybe this will be one of
those CES technologies that we see never
really going anywhere